boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakhyan we
are still on site in manhattan in new
york city new york and we are now at the
new york comedy club which is an amazing
venue that's had a plethora of different
leading comedians that have performed
here over the years and huge shout out
to them for hosting us we are going to
be talking about all things comedy all
things science communication the
importance of these pressing
conversations at this inflection point
in civilization i'm really excited to be
featuring chuck nice hey thanks for
coming on the show man it's great to see
you again you know glad you're here on
the east coast yeah yeah it's always
good you know you do a great job with
you know bringing science
down to earth for people and promoting
science literacy and putting information
out there that and making it accessible
to an audience that otherwise would not
be able
to contact this information so i really
appreciate you chuck thank you so much
for those words and i'll i'll double his
pay afterward that was so good
and oddly enough i'll still be getting
the paid the same
so basically everything chuck said about
me chuck does himself as well chuck's
been he was born in philadelphia he's a
comedian actor television host radio
host podcast host and this is across 46
television shows
which is crazy so it's a just a myriad
of different programming that he's
hosting and co-hosting and he's been
doing comedy for almost two decades now
wow
somehow that sounds really bad
it's great because that's the that's the
accumulation of experience over time
yeah and same thing with all the
programming that you've been on and this
is this is everything um from the radio
chick show all the way to uh playing
with science with star talk um also the
today show all different types of stuff
that you've been a part of yeah
and okay so chuck and i have um oh and
chuck's cool chuck's really cool ted
talk we'll put that link in the bio as
well yeah thanks yeah yeah it's a really
good ted talk a funny look at the
unintended consequences of technology
and again you really take that sort of
you're at the edge of knowledge point
you're like here's biotech here's ai
here's social media's effects on us
i don't really do a deep dive into it
like you would expect from some of the
other ted talks which are far more
narrow in their subject matter uh what i
do is an overarching um broad look at
human interaction and technology and
hopefully
by being funny about it and there are
some thought provoking you know touch
points that say okay yeah you know like
okay this is what we're actually doing
and uh and and technology can be a
little um scary for some
and it can be scary for real
and then the perceptions of it i think
what we think is going to be is going to
be
somewhat but nothing like we think you
know going forward and i i only say that
from
looking at like world's fairs in the
past
but
the difference now is that many
futurists and
people who are driving technology
forward they
it's not coming from a place of wouldn't
it be great if we or what if cars could
fly it's actually a a more algorithmic
progression of technology now and uh as
a result things that you know are
mind-blowing come to fruition so much
quicker
so much quicker which means they also
enter obsolescence so much quicker and
so that's why i think we're not going to
see the future the way we uh imagine it
to be not because it won't actually be
headed in that direction but because
we'll actually skip over some of that
stuff
we have a lot to evolve our own ethics
and our own unity across earth
and we're just leaping to transhumanism
without really figuring out ourselves as
just advanced chimps first wow that now
right there is a whole showing
[Laughter]
no seriously that's a book what you just
said that's a yeah uh
that is kind of what
that's kind of what i uh i fear most
about it and that's kind of what my ted
talk the the very uh you know the final
takeaway from it is really about
you know what you have to do you have to
find out where is your humanity what is
it that makes you a human being what
causes you to be a human being as
opposed to just an advanced ape which is
what we are i mean think about uh i i
watch i've never seen the entire movie
uh but
the
something war of the planet of the apes
or something
and the chimpanzee caesar uh comes into
uh you know all chimps are already
sentient but uh he comes into
a self-awareness that human beings have
that the descartes i i think therefore i
am he has that moment
and then in a moment of defiance he
speaks
and his first word is
no
and i'm like oh that's some real stuff
like that's very very real and
what is it that separates us
from that that i think is the real
question that's a good that's a good way
to put it and i think part of it is our
ability to realize that we were birthed
from the cosmos and that we are
then figuring out how to work together
on this rock and that's part of the
without humans on the rock i think the
rock would just do its normal nature
evolution but humans being stewards of
the rock then make it so that we can
really understand where exactly we came
from we can understand the code of the
universe the math and then we can get
off the rock to the next rocks but we
gotta learn how to have that empathy and
that and that unity and that altruism
and i think that's another thing that
separates us as being able to raise the
baseline of living for everyone around
the planet yeah yeah and you know it's
funny because uh i what you're talking
about um on a more
everyday level i had a conversation with
my wife uh yesterday and we were looking
at you we were
unfortunately watching the news now you
know which we you know we don't do a lot
we read the news more you know because
it gives you a different perspective but
when you watch the news it's scary and
because that's what they're trying to
elicit from you they want they're
selling fear okay let's be honest i mean
you know you don't turn on any cable
news outlet to feel good you actually
and you can become addicted to that you
can come become addicted to that feeling
of oh my god what the hell is happening
oh well you know and and that becomes
what that becomes the commodity that
they're trading it and you know
after about a half hour uh of like
little bits from what's going on around
the world and of course uh domestically
and i i just turned to her and i was
just like the whole world is effed up
because of money
money it's like you could just trace
everything right back to
greed selfishness um
not even self preservation but self
elevation saying i'm better than you so
i should i deserve this you don't uh i
need more and therefore you can't have
uh you know all of these problems come
right back to
humanity
where is our humanity and when you reach
a place
of um
so i i look at it like marriage
good marriage works like this i think
about you before i think about me
and if you just keep doing that for the
rest of your life you will stay married
if you both keep doing that you will
just stay married you can't help it okay
i'm gonna think about you before i think
about me and that can you know if you
were to take that and just knead it out
like dough and expand it to the entire
earth boom guess what
90 something percent of our problems
poof they disappear
yeah they disappear why
humanity yeah where is our humanity and
chuck you bring up this really
interesting point that when we look back
thousands of years and we and we think
about what it was like to approach
someone and ask them
you know oh who owns this land um what
do you mean
this land this is earth's land right
we're just farming on it right this is
just what we do yes and we live on it
and so the whole i and then now another
big thing and we don't typically think
about this one but just in the last
hundred years just the hockey stick of
population that's been it's it's
actually um people moving to metropolis
is for opportunity and the network
effect has crowded these metropolises to
insane degrees and extents and that's
also amazing i wouldn't know what you're
talking about i live in new york
okay we we are doing a lot of big
history and we're doing a lot of uh
civilization design conversation right
now and we'll do more of that in a um
towards the end i want to i want to ask
chuck about um comedy because this this
seems to be
uh
something that it's it's almost an
essence that we carry around with
ourselves it's kind of like humor and
fun and play and it's something we can
carry through from childhood through our
adult life and and you almost you train
your cognition faster to be able to like
make those comedic entries into into
your situations in life and it's really
cool so teach us about how you picked it
up and how you continue to use it in
your you know in your daily life why
it's important
so i don't think i picked it up because
i um okay well i'll tell you my first
comedic experience and when i knew
and
i knew that this was my trajectory in
life okay
i was
giving a speech
in the second grade in front of a
assembly that had
all the students and parents of the
second grade
and i was wearing a bow tie it was part
of the outfit that they asked for me to
wear
and as i was giving the speech which one
you know a lot of kids would be very um
um frightened to get in front of a large
group and that i did not know
that i was supposed to be afraid to
speak in front of a large audience
and that's why i was picked to do it
because
i had this natural inclination to speak
in front of people it didn't bother me
as a matter of fact i was unaware that
there's a large group of people looking
at
um
and i wore a bow tie and it was clip-on
and the teacher didn't clip it on
properly and it fell off in the middle
of my speech
it just it literally hung it dangled
and people started laughing and i didn't
know why and i looked down and when i
looked down it fell and then they
laughed some more and so i bent down i
picked it up and of course i can't see
so i thought i clipped it on and i put
it and it fell again
and i started enjoying the fact that
people were laughing at that then i was
enjoying giving the speech
and and so at that point i just kept
allowing that to happen while and then i
finished the speech and i kept doing it
and the people loved it they loved it
and the teacher was horrified and she
was like in the future something you
should know about the stage when
something goes wrong you don't
acknowledge it you just keep moving
because no one knows that something went
wrong but once you acknowledge it they
are now tuned into that and that's what
they're focused on and i was like no
when you do something wrong you just
keep moving when i do something wrong
i'm gonna have fun with it and make fun
of myself
this is good i loved it i love and you
know from that point forward i knew
something there was something about
laughter that i really enjoy and giving
it like not just like giving laughter
yes i really liked it and i guess a lot
of people would have been
mortified by the fact that
they're they're on stage people are
laughing and they're kind of laughing at
you because you're doing this thing that
didn't bother me at all i liked it and
so that's kind of where it all started
for me that one experience
and what that experience did was it act
it served as a catalyst and i started
looking for ways to make people laugh
and
people were always like you're very
funny you're funny you're funny but
being funny and being a comedian two
totally different things
and i am a performer
but i'm also a comedian and not a lot of
comedians
bring the two together if you notice if
you watch comedy it's a lot of guys
standing and they're like so the other
day i was uh it's more of a conversation
and i don't really like doing that i
like performing i like being animated i
like seeing the different looks on
people's faces but i also love writing
jokes and having a narrative arc and
then having an unexpected or uh ending
to that narrative arc which elicits
laughter and so you know that's kind of
for me
how it all came about um and
i've been doing it almost 20 years i was
on this very stage last night
i did two shows right here and they were
killer shows and so it's the only thing
that i do
that
i've never become bored
you're constantly iterating on your
creative ability through comedy
absolutely and everything
and it
this is why i love science
okay so like i love science because the
more you learn about science
the more you learn there's more science
yeah
it's like that is the greatest thing
about science it's like the more and i
don't care what it is from biology to
neuroscience to the cosmos uh you know
it doesn't make a difference that no
matter what it is you you find something
out and then it becomes more granular
and then it becomes even more granular
and then it's like you can just go so
deep
into and and then you realize oh my god
like that's here but it's also here and
then it's there and then you look at me
like oh my god science is everything is
science
everything well everything is comedy too
yeah and that's what's so cool about it
and that's the two that's what they
share for me is like everything is
comedy and you can find it anywhere and
the greatest joy that i have watching
other comedians which i don't do very
often but the greatest joy that i have
is seeing their perspective and how they
found comedy and something that i
thought there was no comedy and
whatsoever
and it's like like there's a uh a big
question that is asked is there such a
thing as a funny rape joke and i'm like
first of all that's a really lousy
question like you know that's one of
those uh
setup questions you know because you
know it's going to be a controversial
answer but the short answer is yes there
is and i've heard quite a few and it all
depends like i've heard a woman tell and
they're some are offensive and some are
clever but that's what you're really
asking is is it offensive an offense is
something that lies in the ears of the
beholder
yeah there's a lot to talk about right
there i love the story that you gave
about you being a kid it actually
teaches us to not be scared or not be
fearful of taking a leap into something
that is unexplored for us because when
we learn how to do that over and over
again it takes us to the next level it's
like leveling up yeah as a video game
character right and we have to gain
these attributes and skills it's one of
the best ways for us to to learn and
grow and you me and that
that story also that story also speaks
to you know you getting your flow into
the field and then and then i like how
you you know how you talk about there's
always something different about comedy
for every person and then also when you
do watch uh someone else perform you see
what they find to be funny and how they
talk about it and i'm glad you mentioned
the science because
you know we can we can uh we can move
into
your roles in science communication as
as you see the world as all comedy and
all science and the the
interconnectedness of all things period
that it gives you you basically get more
material yeah for comedy by seeing the
world through a scientific ledge
absolutely um
you know and the funny thing is i don't
talk about science in my comedy
um
and people say oh you should you should
do that you know
and it's because i don't have anything
good enough yet but i i have looked like
like i'm working on some things that i
would like to
bring into my act but the thing is this
when you talk about science and i think
it's very important uh when you talk
about science that you have to do it in
such a way that it's inviting
a lot of science right now
i shouldn't say science science is just
science it doesn't do anything one way
or the other a lot of science
communication and and mostly by
scientists people like you
actually open science up to a greater
audience but many scientists and this is
not a knock against them it's just
because they are isolated in their own
community and communication is not
something that they must learn and i
think that part of any science
discipline should be classes in
communication like you should know how
to talk about what this thing that you
love so much and that you're you should
know how to talk about it not in the way
that you would talk to another scientist
but in the way that you would talk to
chuck nice who
may not be the smartest guy in the world
but wants to know
wants to know what you're talking about
and i think that the problem is there's
an intellectual superiority um
complex that many scientists have
rightfully so yeah okay
when someone just because someone says
oh you think you're superior it's like
no i don't think i'm superior
scientists are superior in many ways in
certain areas but we all are superior in
many ways in certain areas
uh i like thinking about it as an edge
so they're they've gone to the edge of
knowledge in a specific field and so
they're trying to talk to other people
at the end at the end so that they can
move the edge forward for society right
and so when when when someone like like
us says how do you make that relatable
for people closer into the center right
then then there's a there's
there are people that want to just be
genius at the edge and not work on the
communication that's just great and
dress fine but don't don't
talk to people
okay you might defer defer them or deter
them away from it right yeah talk to
other scientists don't talk to people
okay because you're doing a disservice
when you talk to people um
you know i look at it like um
nfl analysts and color commentators
the analyst and color commentator
make the they're not necessary
if you like football you don't need to
hear this guy just tell you that that
guy ran five yards and was tackled i
just saw that i don't need you but what
they're doing is they're bringing the
inside
game
outside and it makes you feel like i
know more about football now i
understand this game and then before you
know it you're watching the game and
you'll see it and you're like oh
damn that's holding
you know
they're going to call that play back
that's whole and before you know it here
you are you're coaching yeah
you know what i mean you're coaching the
eagles you're the you know you're the
your coach in kansas city you're just
like
why would they do that like you know
more than the professionals playing the
game
so you think but that's what makes it
exciting for you and so that i think is
what has to happen with um
with science is that we need more people
it's not a spectators right it's not a
spectator but we need more people to
activate other minds so that they
understand this is not relegated to a
bunch of eggheads sitting in a room
discussing ethereal matters this is
actually real life that is happening all
around you at all times and you're a
part of it and you should know
you should know for instance there's a
comedian that will not say his name uh
because i actually know him but he does
a joke about how
molecules are a part of everything which
is true everything has a molecular
structure and there are molecules in my
hand but there's molecules in the air
but my hand when i hit a wall doesn't
pass through
right
first of all it's not molecules that
he's really talking about what he's
really talking about is the space
between atoms and how if you look at the
space between electrons and a nucleus
it's like space itself it's mostly empty
so why is it that things don't pass
through one another and stuff like and
he says and scientists don't know why
that doesn't make any sense i'm like no
scientists do know why what are you
talking about well they do know why
what you're talking about is the fact
that certain things are unobservable and
that's what they don't know but we do
understand why i hit this and my hand
doesn't go through it we do understand
that and so
i always say this because as i was
listening to him i'm like you're doing a
disservice to science like damn man like
you're making people think that
scientists don't understand the most
simple scientific thing when they
actually do and then something said to
me you know what he's telling a joke
lighten the hell up chap seriously why
don't you loosen the molecules in your
ass
and just let the guy tell you at least
he's talking about molecules okay maybe
somebody never thought about molecules
and that could be a good thing so you
know i get that's why like i said i
don't i want to bring science into my
comedy but i want it to be i i really am
reverent i i want it to be something
that is funny but at the same time
thought-provoking you know yeah
the
our our ability to advance
the minds of children and adults to have
a more scientific lens goes hand in hand
with entertainment and comedy creativity
and and seeing the world through that
augmented lens is critical for this
inflection point that we have because if
you know about how some of the
underlying principles of biotechnology
work or how the underlying principles of
ai or neurotech or blockchain and
cryptocurrencies work it'll advance your
ability to have discussion with other
people in your community and around even
federal issues or global issues around
these topics and you know you make a
very important point and that is that um
these
the interconnectedness of science and
your condition
are inexorable they
cannot be separated uh and so the more
you know about it the better off you are
let's just take climate for instance i
mean let's be honest um there are very
many people who see climate and their
belief in whether what i don't call it
climate change anymore or global warming
i call it human cause climate disruption
that's my name for it human-caused
climate disruption it's a lot to say but
you know exactly what you're talking
about
we're doing things and so the climate is
changing we're disrupting the climate
our actions and there are a lot of
people who don't believe that because
they think it's an affront to their
identity
and that's because they don't want to
they're not scientifically literate they
don't want they don't trust science to
begin with and that's a problem uh some
of that is religion or you know based on
religion which i think is terrible
because
i tell people this all the time
if there is a god he invented science
so
you know when the laws of the universe
say this this and this has to happen if
there's a god he's the one or she's the
one or it's the one that made that law
happen so you can't even if even
it doesn't make a difference if uh
you say well scientists are atheists not
true there are many many scientists that
believe in god
um
they just don't attribute the things
that you do
to god
yeah you're making an important point
which we try and make all the time is
that the idea of god is just such a
flexible thing that the god could just
be the what became pre big bang that
caused everything to happen absolutely
and if that is what someone thinks is
god then the code of what we live in is
math physics
right and so then now you were making
this point about climate science and i
want to um and i want to um
anthropogenic or human cause climate
change um chuck would you want to talk
about your project as well oh sure man
so and
anybody
who can help with this we are open if
you're a scientist if you're an
entertainer if you're somebody who can
help with this project i am open to
receiving
whatever it is that you have to bring i
am putting together an effort in the
very first digital youth climate summit
that will happen online that will happen
on youtube because what we're doing is
we're not trying we're trying to bring
the mountain to muhammad we're not
waiting for people to get involved what
we want to do is activate a youth
culture with respect to uh climate
disruption
and climate chaos we want young people
to realize that this is their issue uh
kind of the way the parkland shooting
activated young people to say we're
going to make a change about these gun
this gun bs we call bs that became their
cry for change and we want to do that
with climate with young people between
the ages of 16 and 25 and the reason is
if you're 16 you're going to be voting
very shortly
so you need to ramp up to that and
25 you're probably just out of college
and you're still idealistic
and you know that you can make a change
what has to happen is these people have
to be activated right now everybody has
a cerebral knowledge that climate
uh and climate disruption is actually
happening we see it all the time bigger
storms you know
actually colder uh uh spurts in the
winter along with worms but like it's
chaos it's that's what we know that it's
happening parts per million of co2 in
the atmosphere absolutely so you know
over 400 now uh from 300 absolutely and
the reason why we know that is because
we drill into ice we pull out these
little cor cores and we cut bubbles it's
that simple okay it really isn't like
it's not deep ocean acidification
acidification killing killing coral
reefs and like and it's gorgeous
gorgeous this is part of our soul is the
humans the earth's soul is right there
in those beautiful and we can take so
much inspiration and love and and
understanding of how things evolved as a
planet from it
and the fact is that all these things
are measurable and they're all
interconnected okay so i hate to sound
like you know i'm a character in the
movie avatar just like you saw one
planet is connected you know i see you
like
like but as corny as that is that's
really like the soul of climate
disruption and what you just said it is
all
one thing
okay there's no such thing as weather it
all starts and ends all in the same
place okay and so what we're trying to
do is get young people to say we call bs
and
force political will
force individual change
force and adoption of
alternatives okay and that can be done
with the right amount of pressure
pressure placed upon our politicians
pressure placed upon more importantly
our corporations
and pressure placed ultimately upon
ourselves because you saw what happened
in france um macron said
look
gas is going to be this we're putting
the tax on it and that's a good thing by
the way it's painful change okay
if your shoes are slightly too small
you will walk in them
and you will take them off at the end of
the day and your feet will hurt you will
say
thank god i'm out of those shoes
but if your shoes are a size and a half
too small you will not walk in them you
will be like i didn't do shoes
and that's the kind of change that we
need
and so we need painful change
and that's what he was that but you know
that's what people revolted why because
ultimately we're not putting the onus on
ourselves when it comes down to our
convenience our pocketbook when it comes
down to our lifestyle that's when we go
yeah well no
but guess what all that's going to go
away anyway if we don't do something so
that's the idea behind the movement and
here's what the movement is i did all
that talking and didn't tell you what
the movement was
i didn't tell you what we're doing
what we're doing is we're taking
entertainment only entertainment and
we're messaging everything about climate
through entertainment
so it's scientists and celebrities and
the biggest youtubers on the planet
all coming together to bring this
message in one big program and one
continuing program so that's the whole
thing right there yeah the digital
climates the digital climate summit man
which you know
and uh it's a real it's a real bear to
put together
it's it's a it's a great blend like
you're saying so the powerhouses of of
entertainers the powerhouses of
scientists the powerhouses of
leading youtubers putting piecing these
things together and inspiring the youth
and i like how you say you know it's
about the political change and the
corporate change but it's also about the
youth realizing that we have the power
to become entrepreneurs and artists and
make these big changes through media and
through companies ourselves and then
another thing that that came to mind was
that
there is a
there's a
there's we already have we we talk about
this so much we already have the
resources that we need on earth for the
baseline of living to be extremely high
and sustainable forever and we're not
allocating the resources like it's hard
to just flick it over like a light
switch and transition everything away
from um from fossil fuels to sustainable
forms but we're really just needing to
push all of the marbles over in more
effective ways because we have the
technologies photovoltaics and solar and
we have the technologies for all
different types of of wind resources
and also we have tokamak fusion reactors
that are really we just need more time
investing into them in order to figure
out how to just be able to fuse atoms
and take out more energy than we put in
and then we're abundantly energy filled
forever and that can be used for flying
cars and for all other spaceships and
all of that absolutely and listen all
that stuff can happen and it's really
about the will human will to make it
happen
think of this
go back to the uh before the turn of the
century
and electricity and we had it
but you couldn't turn on a light and
just have left it was saw it was seen as
a novelty like maybe one street lamp
maybe somebody would have some
electricity in their home like
but it was a novelty
now you cannot have society without
electricity
and so that is what happens when you
make a tectonic shift in technology and
that's what we need to do with respect
to climate yeah and that's everything
that you just talked about yeah chuck
what would be your like big um
what would be the most ideal way that
the
this that this digital climate summit
would motivate and then what what change
would you want to see in the political
corporate uh entrepreneurial spheres
with this media so the first thing that
we're trying to do is get people to
force political will uh especially here
in america because america is the
problem okay let's be honest everybody
else is trying to do something about
climate they're not doing enough we know
that but that's because we're not
leading
okay china by the way the china
uh
a lot of you know you hear a lot of
people talk about china they want to be
the world's leading economy and they are
making
huge investments
into solar
huge now the largest solar farm that's
going to be
financed and built
will be financed and built by wait for
it
saudi arabia
that should tell you everything you need
to know
the people
who their one thing they have is oil
they are looking towards solar
farms as the future
come on man that's all we need to know
and what we're what are we doing in
america we are divesting but because we
are divesting that means there's a lot
more money to be made in burning fossil
fuels so the first thing that we're
trying to do is create a political will
amongst people that says hey i'm i'm an
issues voter this is an issue we're not
saying that you have to end fossil fuel
right now which by the way we do but
we're not saying that what we're saying
is we need to start transitioning right
now that's the first thing that we want
to do is make it hey transition we got
to transition okay that's the first
thing the second thing that we want to
do is make it so that corporations
realize that this is an issue for them
and all corporations want to be good
global citizens if it increases their
bottom line and so they can't wait to
tell you
that i'm doing something good look at
what i did corporations are like little
children okay look at what i did i did
something good that's what they need and
so we want to
force them into that position but they
can only be forced in that position if
it means they're going to make money
from it so that's the second thing that
we want to do and the third thing that
we want to do which is chiefly like if
you're not green people will not buy
from you yeah it's that simple it's that
simple it's like wait we see that you
support
the generation of single-use plastics
that actually break down in our oceans
and create uh problems for the ecosystem
and ultimately health problems for us so
guess what we're not going to give you
our money we're going over to this other
company biodegradable that does
biodegradables this other company that
is looking for ways to make sure that
none of this stuff ever enters our
ecosystem that's the company we want to
give our money to guess what will happen
company a
will say we got to change yeah or
bankrupt yep right that's it and so
that's the second thing that we're
trying to do and the third thing that
we're trying to do which is most
important is get people to change their
mind about this thing
and that's the toughest because the
problems which are
manifesting themselves more and more and
we thought well we're seeing the
problems actually happening right now
and so therefore people will have to
take note and they will have to no it
doesn't work that way you see the
problems manifest themselves right now
people look for other ways to deny
that's all they do
so it's kind of like i look at it like
this climate and the population's
american population's uh relationship
with climate
is like a person who's in a relationship
with a cheating spouse and they refuse
to recognize that that person is
cheating on them and we i can't say we
all know someone like that but if you're
old enough you'll meet somebody like
that it's like you
you you know your other your significant
uh they they're yeah they're doing that
with other people and they're doing it
right in front of you i don't believe it
i just can't see them doing that
and that's our relationship with fossil
fuels you know and with earth
and with
i would love to see
an x prize style uh award for um for the
youth to crowd source ideas oh we're
doing work so where that part of the
program is um
we're doing a
film
uh so the show itself is um a
combination of sketch comedy stand-up
short film um
um music
debates uh there will be but they're
they're not real debates
so there i mean it's yeah yeah it's
conversations no uh the only
conversations that will happen are
interstitials in between in between okay
that will happen between celebrities and
scientists okay okay so so the idea is
we want to stay away from
uh didactic uh information dissemination
right do this so that we don't wanna do
that what we wanna do is entertain you
for the entire at the entirety of the
show and at the end hopefully you'll be
like you know what i need to do
something yeah yeah that's what we're
trying to do with specific calls to
action throughout the show itself uh and
so
um
one of the things that we're doing is
we're going to have and hopefully we'll
get um some rich benefactor to be the uh
sponsor of this and x prize for short
film on climate great idea and so
we're putting out the filmmakers all
over the country and you go make your
short film on climate we will feature
you know the top three in the show
itself but the number one show will win
twenty five thousand dollars awesome so
that's part so we're doing things like
that there's so many different facets
that we're trying to incorporate in this
but it's all entertainment driven and
that's the that's the whole idea yeah
this is going to be i hope extremely
watched as in one of the most watched
hopefully videos that ever
you know where we're we're if we get the
right youtubers involved the the the
creators um if we do that then we could
potentially see you know when it's all
said and done you know by time we chop
it up and push it out over social media
and leave it as whole on youtube itself
we could potentially get a hundred
million views that's what we hope for
yes that's what we're hoping and the big
big action push um chuck okay this is a
really important pressing topic that's
it's just it's it's causing a lot of of
unfortunate
madness in in many ways
political correctness
in comedy
i love it
what do we do because there's there's we
gotta retain our ability to
for example if we make fun of each other
we're doing it in good light we're
trying to we're trying to poke and play
with each other and we got to be more
friendly and fun about that but but of
course you can't just you can't be
hurtful and you can't be mean and you
can't right you know but guess what um
there's a couple things has to happen
one weed
you know
some sometimes you have to grow up a
little bit
and realize that not everybody
is going to say and do the right thing
that's number one
um
sometimes people need to be
helped to say and do the right thing and
that's what political correctness is
supposed to be
it's supposed to be that i understand
that saying that is wrong because and
therefore i change the way i speak
because i've changed the way i think
what we're doing now is just it's just
thought police and speech police yeah
it's not political correctness it's
speech policing yeah don't say that
you know and
it's it's like uh
i said to my son
if you ask
me to go
to the there's this rpm it's a speedway
thing i say if you ask me to go to rpm
again
we are not going
so don't ask and he said
that doesn't stop me from not wanting to
go
and that's what we're doing with
political correctness don't say that it
doesn't mean i don't think it and i
don't feel it and that's you know what i
mean so you have a good perspective on
kind of like a spectrum of things
there's the like we should never be
uh treating other human beings as
inferior uh dehumanizing humans through
our speech right so that's like the
horrible and then there's kind of
political correctness which tries on the
beneficial side to help the people move
into uh not dehumanizing others so
that's the good side
and then there's the bad side of
political correctness the thought police
which is making it so when when when
we're humorously trying to poke at
something we're trying to help people
move them forward in different ways
exactly and expand their awareness
especially through humor so for instance
there was a comedian who did a show at
columbia university i forget his name
and he was kicked off the stage for this
joke
um i don't think being gay is a choice
because there are black gay people and
i'm pretty sure they're not looking in
the mirror going you know what this
black thing is just not enough
i need to add something else to this to
make it a little more challenging
right that's a good it's a good joke
and it's actually true it's like why
would you choose to add to your own
misery
by choosing
no you're not choosing to be gay it's
what you are just like you don't choose
to be black all right but the stigma
attached to that remains nonetheless
that's what the joke means but what
people heard was black gang no oh yeah
no you can't say black and gay don't say
black and gay
what the hell is wrong with you and so
that's really and we got to move away
from that here's how we move away from
that back to science
critical thinking
critical thinking allows you to hear a
joke and actually listen to it break it
down and go okay i get it i get that
um
yes that's not offensive i see what
you're actually trying to say
instead of just a nuance right instead
of just hearing trigger words and going
your head explodes and by the way you
know everybody says well you know
political correctness is how donald
trump came into power no donald trump
came into power because he actually
tapped into a certain
uh angst
one
uh fear
two
racism three all the darker elements of
our humanity he was able to bring them
together and coalesce them into what
seemed like a positive movement
and so that's how he came to power okay
but the truth is that people
felt
connected to him because he said things
that were
unacceptable
and they were like you know what i like
that guy he's saying i don't even agree
what he just but i just like the fact
that he said you know what he's an idiot
as far as i'm concerned but i just like
the fact that he said the bull in the
china shop exactly and so you know this
is what pc this is this is kind of the
backlash to pc and we got to get away
from
you know we got to get away from pc in
that way i'm going to i'm going to make
a reach here i think this might be a
decent way to put it is that there are
so many good uh practitioners of islam
that are not getting the voice that they
need to call out the radical islamists
that are killing apostates right and so
in this sense with with political
correctness it would be like we there's
this the ones that are screaming from
the rooftops about the
the issues with their obsession with
being um like a hurt by by other by
other people's words they're the ones
with the loudest megaphone but the ones
that should have the megaphone are the
ones that say hey i'm learning something
from seeing it through this comedic
perspective i'm seeing the nuance on
this issue like with that joke so it's
again it's shifting the megaphones
okay chuck a couple quick questions on
the way out sure um okay we like to ask
these on the show what is a core driving
principle of yours
oh man um
wow
that's a really good question and it's
so personal
like
but um
my core driving principle is i always
want to be a better person
how can i be a better person how can i
be better at
being a comedian how do i take comedy
and do something good with it how can i
be a better father how am i how can i
introduce my children into society so
that they are now an asset to society
and not a detriment how can i be a
better husband how can i be a better
friend how can i be a better
communicator like being better in
moving better towards something good for
other people that's my driving principle
you know now i fail at that all the time
we all do yeah we all do i'm an abject
failure when it comes to it but it's
what i seek it's what i truly want um
and i i i think that the world could be
a better place if we all did that i'm
basically a hippie
i really am i mean i'm like i am i was
born at the wrong time i am basically a
hit i just missed the i said i should
have got i should have been right there
in the 60s man i just missed my time
because i would have been spinning
around in the mud you know
with some uh lsd and my system i don't
care like you know i'm
i like how chuck is
really clear that when we look at the
mirror and see ourselves and we're
trying to help make ourselves a better
person that we're not going to succeed
100 efficiency from moment one you don't
start syncing three pointers so you you
slowly work on yourself maybe you
succeed one out of ten changes then two
out of ten changes in each year moving
on each month and so yeah that's a
that's a good way across all these
different facets yeah and it goes it
goes all the way across you know like i
i used to scream at my son and i
sometimes i got admit i still do but you
know because my father screamed at me
and that's how it works right but i find
myself like last night i came home from
work right here on this stage and um
i walked in the house and it was 1 30
and he was up playing video games and i
i went and i just went like this
[Laughter]
he went okay dad yeah
okay
instead of screaming just standing in
front of him and doing like breathe like
all right dude i am upset like guess
what and it was so much more effective
than like what are you doing like and so
like that's what i'm talking about like
and and that shows got it right yeah and
that also shows him like okay maybe
there's a better way to communicate yeah
yeah so you know that's great i love
that chuck such a good example yeah yeah
and that speaks to our um inclination to
be more meditative um yeah i love that
okay if you could rebuild
civilization from scratch wow how would
you design it wow
um
i'm going to answer that with a
non-answer it would not make a
difference because we would [ __ ] it up
[Laughter]
uh to be honest there uh
the the problem with civilization will
always be human beings and so the idea
now by the way we are the best human
beings we've ever been in the history of
human beings right now and people look
around and go the world is a mess and
things are terrible we are the best
human beings to ever cross this planet
okay as as a world there's always been
war there's always been cruelty there's
always been uh human degradation
but
think about this not too long ago when
you look at the history of this globe
not too long ago and i back ago
romans were feeding people to the lions
for entertainment
okay
fights to the death were are you not
entertained okay
we don't do that now it's still within
us
but we resist that
and so
um how would i build it from from the
ground up i would make
um
i uh oh man wow i just got it it just
flashed into my head
we were talking about planet of the apes
earlier and the ape shall never kill egg
like i'd start there yeah yeah that's a
good one that's a good first principle
that's it i just start with that
principle like that's the first thing
that everyone learns no matter what like
the one thing you can do to deny a
person everything is to take their life
so that's let's start there
and then it's like well if i can't kill
you
well i guess i gotta learn how to get
along with you
because the ultimate can't the ultimate
solution cannot happen i cannot so now
okay now we got to figure out what is it
that allows us to come together a mesh
because i can't kill you so that would
be my that'd be my ground up from
scratch
it's a good first line of code yeah
exactly okay um two more um this
wouldn't be simulation if we didn't ask
you do you think we're in a simulation
i think it we could be to be honest i
mean it makes sense i mean let's just
say if this were just a mathematical
construct uh we would not know
okay we would not know i mean you think
about it think about this
i'll give you an idea and let you know
einstein had a mathematical construct
for gravity waves
it worked mathematically and no one knew
if it existed or not
and then we got empirical evidence that
that mathematical construct was actually
the case
okay
um gravity itself what calls one planet
to another celestial body and causes
that body to be trapped in its or okay
that was a mathematical construct first
and then it became a reality all right
so
you say are we in a simulation we very
well could be it could just be a
mathematical construct down on its most
granular atomic subatomic level it's
just as matters when it comes to matters
of particles and how they be could just
be an equation and that could be well
this could be a simulation you don't
know
does it make a difference no i still owe
visa 230 at the end of this month
so
that's the real is it don't make a
difference because you got to live in
the simulation if it is a simulation
it's a good thought experiment for
adding a scientific lens to our reality
right and also to
potentially realizing that we want to
level up in the in the game we want to
gain as many skill points in this game
as possible and those skill points come
from helping people being a better
person
creating a sense of unity and value for
the world um okay well that's cool yeah
that's a cool video game
i wouldn't mind living in that video
that's your video game that's my video
that's our video game so yeah yeah um
okay last question is what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
i'm going to go with extra soft toilet
paper
and i only say that because when you
live without it for a while you really
do understand just how sublime it is
um no
no um
i'm going to say and this sounds very
um
corny love is the most beautiful thing
in the world
and that's because it transcends
everything and it
we don't know
if
it
can be commuted to other animals but i
think it can when you hear about a dog
that walks all the way across the
continental united states to find an
owner and that's a real story
when you look at
people who do superhuman feats of
strength because they are that's love
that's them actually looking at another
person and summoning a
love
for
humanity for their fellow person and
saying i gotta do something uh when you
look at how uh the connections that you
can make just between your own family
members and then see those connections
actually extend to people that are
outside of your family i think that that
is unbelievable i think that's the most
beautiful thing in the world is love and
and when it expresses itself in
self-sacrifice it becomes that much more
beautiful
yeah
very very well said thank you chuck yeah
man thank you it's such a pleasure to
see you brother this has been a great
episode
i greatly appreciate having you on the
show and your ambitions in science
communication and inspiration and comedy
are so great and we're just honored to
have you thank you thank you keep up the
good work well thank you you do today
thank you we will thanks everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate you we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below let us know some of your
thoughts about topics we were talking
about also check out the links in the
bio to the digital climate summit
chuck's work check those out for us
also help join us join us for simulation
so we can help doing cool things like
coming on site to great places like this
and speaking with epic leaders and much
love build the future manifest your
destiny into the world everyone much
love see you soon peace
that's it my brother dude sounds great
good job good to see you man